[Musik]
ich begrüße sie sehr herzlich zu einer
neuen ausgabe von unter den linden nach
den landtagswahlen der letzten wochen
menschlich holstein und nordrhein
westfalen werden dort die ersten weichen
richtung koalitionen gestellt und der
wahlkampfmodus scheint beendet
aber nach den wahlen es bekanntlich
immer schon wieder vor den wahlen die
bundestagswahl wirft ihre schatten
voraus welche themen werden diesen
wahlkampf bestimmen soziale
gerechtigkeit oder er in sicherheit was
mobilisiert den wähler mehr konkrete
politik in sachfragen oder das große
ganze das thema europa ist sehr abstrakt
und eignet sich bisher eigentlich
schlecht für wahlkämpfe aber das ist
inzwischen anders die aufmerksamkeit für
die wahlen in den niederlanden und in
frankreich haben bewiesen die zukunft
europas ist als politisches thema im
zentrum der menschen angekommen
nachdem brad pitt und den erstarrten der
eu-kritiker war die erleichterung über
den wahlsieg immer neuer kurs in
frankreich und in deutschland groß aber
über europa reden reicht jetzt nicht
mehr in europa muss gehandelt werden
konkrete forderungen zum umbau der eu
liegen auf dem tisch
und sie sind geeignet den
bundestagswahlkampf zu prägen
denn es geht ums geld dass deutsches
steuergeld darüber möchte ich heute
sprechen zum einen mit dietmar bartsch
den fraktionsvorsitzenden der partei die
linke im deutschen bundestag und mit
professor hand seiner sinn langjähriger
präsident des ifo-instituts und vor
allen dingen einer der gefragtesten
ökonomen europa fertig bekommen und
[Applaus]
sie haben sich in einem interview
gefragt besagte auf die welche rolle
europa im bundestagswahlkampf spielen
sollte das dass das zentrale
wahlkampfthema sein soll vor allen
dingen an gewicht der agenda makro und
wir sollten darauf eine deutsche antwort
formulieren ohne dass die wird schon auf
geht auf die forderung von markierung im
detail eingehen
aber was würden sie sagen nun eignen
sich die vorschläge für eine reform
europa wir sind ja nun alle froh dass es
nicht marin gesehen wurde
aber was man so alles fordert ist von
weitgehend frankreich hängt ja in den
seilen
das verarbeitende gewerbe ist noch zwölf
prozent unter dem niveau von 2007 vor
krise vor zehn jahren und man weiß nicht
ein noch aus die kunden frankreichs in
südeuropa hatten schwierigkeiten und
jetzt fordert er ein großes
transferprogramm um letztlich
steuermittel vom norden in den süden zu
übertragen und auch bonität zu
übertragen so dass die sich verschulden
können damit die nachfrage nach
französischen waren gerettet bleibt so
sich auf eine kurze formel gebracht das
was er vorhat natürlich müssen wir in
europa vorangehen
aber es ist die frage ob wir in dieser
form voran gehen sollen es gibt ganz
andere themen was gucken uns jetzt
nochmal an
die kanzlerin ist ein bisschen abwarten
was die vorschläge von makro angeht die
spd die durch mit wohlwollen und auch
mit unterstützung die linke harder
teilweise mit balkon das ganze doch so
ein bisschen zerstritten oder wie muss
man bewerten wenn sie jetzt kanzlerin
spd und linke dann ist das zerstritten
es gibt auch nicht die deutsche lösung
es gibt ja unterschiedliche angebote
fakt ist dass neben dem thema des
sozialen zusammenhalts in deutschland
das europäische thema diese
bundestagswahl auseinandersetzung
mitbestimmen will wird und eines ist
auch ganz klar dass der bisherige weg
offensichtlich kein erfolgreicher war
man muss ja nur die ergebnisse anschauen
sind hat über frankreich gesprochen aber
man kann sich europa anschauen
wir haben das erstarken
rechtspopulistischer teilweise
faschistische parteien wir haben eine
jugendarbeitslosigkeit in den südländern
von über 50 prozent in griechenland in
spanien wächst eine generation der
hoffnungslosigkeit heran und die
ökonomischen ungleichgewichte werden
immer größer deutschland partizipiert
davon aber das wird dauerhaft nicht gut
gehen der praxis ist ein alarmzeichen
die wahl von frau le pen ein drittel
dass wir finden das alle furchtbar ist
ein alarmzeichen weil es sagt etwas aus
über politik und deswegen muss man auch
in deutschland darüber streiten ich
finde ja schon interessant dass auf
einmal herr mack rang in deutschland nur
noch partner hat als die kanzlerin
umarmt ihn
herr gabriel fährt auf den flughafen
herr schulz ist der beste freund
also man sonst sich ein bisschen in der
jugendlichkeit ich habe allerdings so
die befürchtung dass im oktober diese
freundschaft vorbei sein wird
denn das was immer gefordert und das ist
herr schäuble bisher gemacht hat das
widerspricht sich und da muss man drüber
diskutieren auch in deutschland ich
glaube man muss auch ehrlich sein muss
ehrlich sein und zunächst mal
konstatieren so weiter kann es nicht
gehen weil dann gefährden wir das große
projekt europas und angesichts der
situation in den vereinigten staaten wo
ein wahnsinniger präsident geworden ist
muss europa stark sein es ist derzeit
allerdings in diesem zustand in diesen
laden zustand und herbert statistischen
angesprochen independent war durchaus
die andere kandidatin bei den wahlen in
frankreich viele sagen jetzt denn wir
die chance mit macronix nutzen dann ist
tatsächlich die nächste wahl für le pen
schon quasi entschieden
sehen sie das auch so das ist möglich
allerdings weiß ich nicht was
deutschland wirklich tun kann also um so
mit geld das problem südeuropas zu lesen
ist es viel zu groß so viel geld gibt es
gar nicht beziehungsweise so viel geld
würden wir auch im extremsten fall gar
nicht auf den tisch legen
marine le pen bleibt in wartestellung
und wird versuchen jedwede schwäche von
makro- und auch die probleme der
französischen wirtschaft für sich
auszunutzen und diese probleme sind in
der tat gravierend die sind so
gravierend dass sie nicht mit 1 1 mit
ein paar politikmaßnahmen beiseite
geschoben werden können wir haben ein
fundamentales ungleichgewicht in der
eurozone
das sollte man erkennen dass uns vor ein
großes dilemma stellt dieses
ungleichgewicht besteht darin dass als
der euro eingeführt wurde er die zinsen
zu denen sich die südlichen länder
verschulden konnten dramatisch gesenkt
hat er spanien italien portugal 5
prozentpunkte weniger und dann haben die
sicht verschuldet und haben die löhne im
staatssektor vergrößert haben eingebaut
so dass die löhne im bau steigen konnten
alles kreditfinanzierte lohnerhöhung die
weit über die produktivitätszuwächse
hinausging und haben diese länder
überteuerte dramatisch überteuert wir
haben deutschland mit seinen preisen am
boden blieb gingen dort die preise in
den himmel und das hat die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit zerstört und jetzt
weiß man nicht ein noch aus
das ist doch genau das passiert
das drücke ich jetzt einfach noch mal
kurz auf das interview ein
ich würde gerne natürlich am anfang
schon zitiert habe denn herr in hat da
aufgeführt ist es einfach jetzt die
frage ist in welchem europa wie
zukünftig leben wollen ist das eine
union die sich als sozialistischer
haftungsgemeinschaft versteht oder
wollen wir eine partnerschaftliche
gemeinschaft und ist das eine von dem
anderen überhaupt verbrennen wird hier
negativ gemeint also ich würde das immer
positiv interpretiert ich will aber noch
mal wirklich auf das grundlegende
zurückkommen in der beschreibung ist ja
zunächst erstmal bei der beschreibung
festzustellen dass es so ist aber es hat
eben damit zu tun dass deutschland ein
extrem niedriglohnsektor ausgebaut hat
dass unsere kosten
so niedrig sind dass wir diesen
exportüberschuss erringen konnten das
hat er nicht mehr nur mit deutscher
innovations- kunst und ingenieurskunst
zu tun sondern mit einem ausgeweiteten
niedriglohnsektor und deswegen muss man
natürlich an beide seiten fragen
stellung ich sage wir haben
grundsätzliche fehler bei der
konstituierung europas gemacht das hat
die linke damals euro so nicht bei
unsere forderungen
das hat damit zu tun dass wir keine
sozialen union haben das hat damit zu
tun dass es keine ausgleiche
ursprünglich gegeben hat jetzt wird das
über hintertüren gemacht fakt ist wir
brauchen was die schulden betrifft für
europa eine lösung deswegen ist unsere
forderung seit langem
wir brauchen eine europäische schulden
konferenz nicht so wie jetzt wir müssen
wir bei griechenland gucken wir müssen
da mal gucken diese frage muss auf den
tisch und sie muss gelöst werden
die ezb muss eine andere politik machen
dass es derzeit gemacht wird immer mehr
geld in den markt zu null zins ist der
falsche weg wir brauchen die
investitionen in den ländern
da kann europa viel mehr machen und zwar
in frankreich in griechenland in anderen
ländern sonst wird das schiefgehen
am ende des tages brauchen wir natürlich
eine transferunion ist es anders ist
überhaupt nicht denkbar weil wir
ansonsten dass europa zerstören dass
meine feste überzeugung und da gibt es
natürlich eine vielzahl von dingwerth
ist es leider so dass europa in allen
zentralen fragen versagt kritik der brad
pitt hat nicht nur ökonomische sondern
das hat damit zu tun dass in der
flüchtlingsfrage europa völlig
gescheitert ist und ganz ohne anderer
die klinken sich völlig aus deutschland
hat dort mehr verantwortung als andere
übernommen
das geht so nicht in der
finanzmarktkrise die banken wurden
gerettet in größenordnung aber es gibt
weiterhin keine lösung wir haben einen
in frankreich in griechenland in
deutschland teilweise obszönen reichtum
und das da muss man rangehen und sagen
das wollen wir anders denn es ist nicht
nur eine finanzpolitische fragen eine
frage des euros in den vereinigten
staaten gibt den dollar und zwischen den
einzelnen bundesstaaten ist die
ökonomische leistungsfähigkeit
deutschlands unterschied deutlich
unterschiedlich und auch in der
bundesrepublik deutschland der abstand
zwischen mecklenburg vorpommern und
bayern ist größer als der prozentuale
als zwischen deutschland
griechenland also es muss ja
offensichtlich möglich sein aber da es
natürlich das politische bekenntnis ein
unterschied und da ist meine große sorge
da die große sorge dass jetzt bei den
bundestagswahlen sehr populistisch über
die frage geredet geben wir geld an die
länder das ist gar nicht dieses problem
am ende des tages wird es darauf
hinauslaufen ist nur die frage wann und
wie es muss darum gehen wie wollen wir
europa neu konstituieren damit ein
europa der menschen wird denn das darf
man nicht vergessen
der grundgedanke europas war ein gedanke
eine friedensunion zu schaffen
und wenn wir so weitermachen wenn die
auseinandersetzung so größer werden
gefährden wir genau das projekt bin
dagegen dass wir das nur ökonomisch
betrachten und feststellen habe ich
neulich gewesen verglichen ganz auf
einem guten weg ich glaube ich höre
nicht richtig
man muss man mit den leuten dort reden
wie die lage dort im land ist es ist
eine katastrophe und zwar dadurch dass
griechenland zwar demokratisch
entscheidet aber deutschland festlegt
was zu machen ist
er warf deren quasi schon alle themen
jetzt einmal erwähnt aber sortiment
anbieten oder gucken beim ein bisschen
noch mal neu konstituieren hat herr
bartsch gesagt müsse sich europa nach
den bundestagswahlen wir einfach noch
mal drauf schauen
es ist ein reizthema wieder überall zu
lesen ist das thema eurobonds
wie hat man das in seinen forderungen
für europa gemeint wird es welche geben
und wäre dafür vereins ja ist ja ein
bisschen zurück gerudert bei der
pressekonferenz in dem er gesagt hat
euro-bund bonds an anstelle der
altschulden villa nicht aber was er
natürlich sind eurobonds für neue
schulden will ein europäisches bgr
gelangt finanzminister will ein eigenes
parlament für die eurozone
und er will eine eigene eu-steuer wo
also die eu zugreifen kann
in den einzelnen ländern nach eigenem
messen mit mit ihrer steuer sind
verletzt ein eigenes parlament zu haben
euro parlamente haben also ich wäre sehr
problematisch weil meine begriffe in der
versuch den euro zu verdichten zu
mehrstaatlichkeit europa auch teilen
kann
denn man muss ja bedenken viele länder
sind ja gar nicht im euro die in der eu
sind nicht jetzt ist england schon
abgespalten die sind ganz raus aus der
eu aber im norden dänemark schweden und
sind nicht im euro im osten polen die
tschechische republik ungarn rumänien
bulgarien sind nicht im euro und wenn
wir jetzt den euro wir verdichten zu
einer art von staat dann ziehen wir eine
trennlinie um deutschland herum im
norden und im osten und spalten europa
der ratspräsident der polnische
ratspräsidenten jetzt gegen die wünsche
der eigenen regierung ja noch mal
wiedergewählt wurde hat dazu gesagt dass
europa der zwei geschwindigkeiten was
man hier vorhat ist im grunde das was
wir schon hatten bis 1989 das brauchen
wir nicht noch einmal wiedersehen mit
einem europarlament ist ein verbrechen
oder verdammt sozusagen ein gespaltenes
europa haben oder einer hyper dass das
parallel fährt an gewissen stellen wie
gut die gefahr ist natürlich da das
hängt davon ab wie man das gestaltet
aber ich bin schon der auffassung dass
wir zunächst mal eine europäische
wirtschaftspolitik auch ich finde es
wirklich zentral denn so lange ist so
dass auch ein minister also am ende des
tages einen europäischen
wirtschaftsminister kann ich mir sehr
gut vorstellen
und wenn es dann wirklich eine
finanzpolitische verlagerung gibt dass
sich deshalb als schwierig an reis ich
glaube da in deutschland mehrheiten
nahezu nicht zu erringen sind also als
ehemalige haushaltspolitiker habe ich
sowieso eine gewisse sorge diese
wirklich naja die höchste form letztlich
die das parlament hat wenn ich wirklich
das budgetrecht das abzugeben ist ein
problem aber letztlich muss man auch
darüber reden das finde ich aber ist ein
endpunkt ich glaube dass man vorher
wirklich darüber nachdenken muss ob die
europäischen verträge wie sie denn jetzt
sind wir einiges ausschließen
ob das das wirklich so weitergehen kann
denn am ende bleibt 1 wenn wir nicht
strukturpolitisch ländern auch
unterstützung geben und zwar im
investitionsbereich wir haben immer von
einem marshallplan für griechenland
gesprochen
in frankreich ist die situation nicht so
anders moment wird sehr wenig über
italien geredet da sind die probleme
aber mit am größten und sage ihnen eins
wenn noch ein weiteres land nach
großbritannien aus dem euro raus geht
dann wird die union in dieser form nicht
mehr existiert und das ist die
schlüsselfrage ist wirklich gerne hätten
auch meiner fragen sie haben ja gerade
gesagt hat sich für problematisch halten
durchaus wenn dort parallel jetzt noch
mal ein euro parlament aber ist es nicht
trotzdem erforderlich dass gerade die
euro-länder sich viel stärker zusammen
stellen und vielleicht sogar einen
eigenen minister auch haben ja gibt es
natürlich zusammen aber nicht speziell
die euro-länder sondern die eu-länder
müssen zusammenhalten ich würde den
schwerpunkt im lädt er schon setzen und
bei der sicherheitspartnerschaft um auf
die grundidee zurückzukommen
die die väter europas hatten nach dem
kriege aber was griechenland betrifft
sie haben es gerade erwähnt marshallplan
griechenland hat mittel bekommen von der
europäischen zentralbank und von den
rettungsschirmen die kommen gleich etwa
36 marshall pläne sind nämlich 180
prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes woher
dieses geld wurde zu einem drittel
verwendet um die banken zu retten die
investiert hat nämlich gelernt ein zu
einem drittel wurde es verwendet für den
griechen lebensstandard und zu einem
drittel wurde es perverser weise
verwendet um investitionen im ausland zu
finanzieren was die griechen in einem
riesigen umfang getan haben sollte
selbst hier in berlin haben griechische
wohnungsbaugesellschaften objekte
gekauft das muss man sich mal vorstellen
und haben die preise hochgetrieben
das land stimmte ja in öffentlichen
mitteln die gewährt wurden also so geht
das nicht sondern wird es geht europa
nur auf der basis eines haftungsprinzip
jeder muss mit seinem eigenen geld
auskommen wir können keine
transfer-union machen 40 prozent der
bevölkerung der eurozone wohnen in
krisenländern er sollen die anderen 60
die 40 bezahlen und ist frankreich auch
noch ein krisenland dann hätten wir ja
60 prozent der bevölkerung die von 40
bezahlt werden müssen es ist völlig
unmöglich und es kommt hinzu dass die
länder die die gelder empfangen dann ja
auch permanent in ihrer arbeitslosigkeit
gehalten werden nochmal das hauptproblem
ist sie kamen durch die kreditblase auf
ein zu hohes preisniveau es gab also
eine dynamische entwicklung mit
explodierenden preisen und löhnen und
jetzt können sie nicht mehr abwerten
weil sie im euro sind und er sind nicht
wettbewerbsfähig sollen wir diese
wettbewerbs diese fehlende
wettbewerbsfähigkeit durch transfers vom
norden finanzieren wenn wir das tun dann
bleiben sie immer so teuer wie sie sind
ja sie kommen nie auf den grüns wir
haben also ein echtes was sollten sie
ich glaube wir brauchen eine atmende
währungsunion wo auch länder austreten
können herr schäuble hatte ja im jahr
2015 mit griechenland diesen vorschlag
entwickelt 15 europäische finanzminister
waren auf seiner seite
man wollte griechenland den weg zum
austritt ebenen und warum facc ist der
griechische finanzminister hat ja auch
schon einen geheimen plan für den
austritt aus dem euro entwickelt der
wurde dann nur später von höherer warte
nämlich merkel und roland abgeblockt sie
mussten drinbleiben es gab wieder geld
aber die lösung geht nicht wir können
nicht länder die im euro wettbewerblich
nicht zurechtkommen mit dem geld anderer
staaten dauerhaft durch finanzieren
es wird viel zu teuer und es führt dazu
dass diese länder geben ihre
wettbewerbsfähigkeit nie verlieren
griechenland hat heute lohnkosten die
sind pro stunde doppelt so hoch wie in
polen
das land kommt ja auf einer liste
möglicher standorte in europa für
investoren überhaupt nicht mehr vor
wir machen einen großen bogen drum herum
das ist der weg der überhaupt nicht geht
und so viel geld gibt es nicht auf der
welt um die südeuropäischen länder durch
zu finanzieren während sie nicht
wettbewerbsfähig sind das müssen sie
schaffen die wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu
erreichen und notfalls durch den
austritt den euro zu stilisieren zu
einem ziel an sich halte ich für falsch
ich bin nicht dafür auszutreten dass wir
das ganze auflösen wollen ihn halten
aber an den rändern sollten wir aus
dritte ermöglichen
das ist besser als diese länder zu
finanzieren der währungsunion den
rändern viel kaputtmachen des euros das
war normal plädoyer für den wechsel der
cracks
wenn jemand an den rändern her sagte
austritt dann ist der europa sie sich
noch heute nicht ausreden und außerdem
sieht es wirklich vorgesehen aber das
können wir alles lassen ich glaube dass
eine stimmt griechenland hat unter der
konservativen regierung das land
wirklich an den abgrund gebracht und
zwar genau dadurch ist ein wahlgeschenke
finanziert vor einem öffentlichen dienst
an anderen stellen und da wurde die
beiden parteien die christdemokraten und
die sozialdemokraten immer wieder
gewählt das system kaputt gekannt das
ist wahr
ein ergebnis dann die wahl von zebras
gewesen aber was nicht stimmt die
auflagen und das geld was da
hingeflossen ist so wird das grobe dazu
bedient staatsschulden dass
staatsschulden wirklich immer wieder
umzuschichten und fakt ist dass
griechenland jetzt für seine wiesen
schulden günstige zinsen
das ist war es umgeschuldet worden die
sind nach hinten geschoben worden
das alles war die stehen im moment auf
dem papier da wird es obwohl ja herr
schäuble andere gesagt haben und wird
nun über die altschulden reden da wird
es eine vereinbarung geben da bin ich
ganz sicher
fakt ist es wird ohne investitionen in
dem land in griechenland in anderen
südländern keinen aufschub geben die
bisherigen sogenannten reformen haben zu
einer verarmung der bevölkerung geführt
und eingewechselt hätte dieses nochmals
verschärft das mag der ökonomisch
vielleicht sinn machen
das ist real so dass das land in eine
katastrophe gekommen wäre schon jetzt
war es ja so dass dort unruhen in
griechenland gegeben hat man muss sich
das nur angucken wie das dort ein
flüchtling war es der falsche weg weil
der markt vielleicht ökonomischer
bereich bad gut sein für die menschen
ist es dass auf keinen fall deswegen bin
ich der festen überzeugung dass man aus
dem was herr draghi jetzt zinsfrei am
geldmarkt punkt punkt wenn man das
wirklich für investitionen damit
attraktion erhöhte also mal ein beispiel
sagt es ist doch völlig irre dass wir in
deutschland also bei der solarenergie
ziemlich weit vorne sind wenn ich mich
recht entsinne scheint in griechenland
mehr die sonne
da gibt es phasen urlaub es muss doch
vielleicht eine attraktion geben dort zu
investieren es gibt andere punkte aber
dafür wird dort privatisiert die häfen
werden verscherbelt die flughafen werden
verschärft und am ende dieses land nicht
besser sondern schlechter dastehen ich
hätte mir gewünscht dass man dann mal
wirklich in griechenland vielen anderen
ländern das ungleichgewicht in dem man
bei den vermögenden mal eingreifen indem
man griechenland erlässt das ist diese
ganzen wahnsinnigen rüstungsprojekte
griechen hat aber als einziges land
militär etat von über zwei prozent
das sind alles verträge die früher
gemacht worden sind hätte man auch sagen
können die wollen wir nicht mehr das ist
im sinne von griechenland aber nein das
sind im wesentlichen auch deutsche
firmen also werden die ordentlich
gekauft das militär zeug das sind die
fehler man muss um steuern dass es war
aber wenn man da hin orientiert dass der
euro oder dass länder aus dem euro
austreten können und hier war es kein
austritt hier sollte ein exempel
statuiert werden weder alexis tsipras
noch die regierung der sogenannte
geheimplan von neurofocus wäre der
gewesen wenn man weiter gepresst hätte
und sie keine chance gehabt hätte aber
es ist anders gelaufen die wollten das
nicht und aus welchem grund sollten sie
austreten damit die bevölkerung noch
weiter verarmt das kann nur der falsche
weg sein aber richtiges 1 wir brauchen
grundlegende reform und das heißt für
europa eine wirtschaftspolitik die
ermöglicht ausgleich zu schaffen
das heißt eine sozialpolitik zu
realisieren
die attraktion erhöht das ist der weg
das ist aber nicht kurzfristig machbar
das ist auch nicht über klar theorie
kann ich ja das ist ja auch nicht
irgendwie
der besonders links noch besonders
rechts was sonst irgendwas auszutreten
abwertung möglichkeiten haben das über
jahre in den südländern früher gelaufen
aber auch nicht nur mit positiven
ergebnissen könnte man noch darüber
streiten warum ist kriegen dann
überhaupt in die in union gekommen und
unten an das vergossene milch das
vergossene aber auch heute ihre heute
muss es darum gehen wenn man europa
zusammenhalten will und muss man das
bekenntnis dazu haben eine korrigierte
politik der ezb haben wir brauchen eine
gemeinsame wirtschaftspolitik und man
muss finanzpolitisch neu agieren nicht
unter dem diktat von merkel und schäuble
denn das hat europa in die situation
gegeben darum geht zu wie bei der
bundestagswahl noch mal dazu also wenn
das wirklich so schlecht wäre für
griechenland frage ich mich warum warum
marquis dem kabinett am abend nach dem
referendum die hatten ja dieses programm
der länder strikt abgelehnt den kabinett
vorgeschlagen hat auszutreten
er hat es ja aus das kabinett hat es
dann nicht akzeptiert und bürokratisch
ist dann zurückgetreten aber wir können
noch warum dies nicht unterstellen dass
er etwas vorgeschlagen hat was schlecht
gewesen wäre für die kriegs zu
bevölkerung im gegenteil wäre sehr gut
gewesen weil der austritt und die
abwertung dem lang die chance gegeben
hätte wieder wettbewerbsfähig zu werden
die drachen die sie dann bekommen hätten
wenn profis sich durchgesetzt hätte
hätte abgewertet sagen wir mal auf die
hälfte die importpreise wären aufs
doppelte gestiegen
das hätte probleme geschaffen man hätte
auch helfen müssen bei sensiblen
importen seitens der eu aber der vorteil
wäre gewesen die die leute hätten nicht
mehr die importwaren so stark gekauft
sondern wären zu ihren eigenen
herstellern gegangen die griechen kaufen
der tomaten in holland sie kaufen
olivenöl in deutschland das ist absurd
sie hätten dann wären dann zu ihren
bauern gegangen und hätten die sachen
dort gekauft und die bauern hätten
wieder leute eingestellt vielleicht wäre
auch die alte baumwollindustrie die mal
stark war in griechenland und durch den
euro kaputt gemacht wurde
wieder hochgekommen also es hätte eine
wirtschaftliche belebung gegeben und im
übrigen werden die reichen griechen die
ihr geld im ausland in sicherheit
gebracht haben zum teil zurück gekehrt
hätten immobilien gekauft hätten sie
renoviert das hätte ein bauboom gegeben
und diese beiden effekte ziehen
das ifo-institut dem ich ja vorstand
hatte eine studie gemacht mit 71 ländern
die in der nachkriegszeit eine
wettbewerbsprobleme und probleme des
stars konkurses hatten und die dann
abwerteten und zeigte sich dass in fast
allen fällen nach ein zwei jahren diese
abwertung zu einem starken
wirtschaftsaufschwung geführt hat nur so
lassen sich jobs für die jungen menschen
schaffen die transfers die wir geben die
gehen an die rentner nichts gegen die
rentner aber die gehen schaffen keine
jobs für junge leute
wir haben also fast 50 prozent
jugendarbeitslosigkeit in griechenland
dieser weg versündigt sich an einer
ganzen generation von dem ich würde
gerne noch mal wieder über widersprechen
weil wissen sie sagt das noch mal
es mag ja sein dass man bei einer
ökonomischen betrachtung da hinkommen
kann abwertung kann zu
wirtschaftsaufschwung führen das will
ich überhaupt nicht leuten nur eins ist
definitiv sie hätten damit für die
menschen die jetzt schon daten noch mal
einen absprung organisiert und nicht
anders und sie haben ja recht das war
herr buckle es gab in der regierung
niemanden im übrigen bei allen anderen
parteien gab es auch niemanden oder kaum
jemand der gesagt hat wir sind jetzt
schön drexel
das ist nicht im griechischen interesse
weil es die menschen in größter armut
trifft sie haben einen zentralen punkt
angesprochen warum ist das eigentlich so
und da hätte man lange eingreifen müssen
dass die wahnsinnig reichen griechen
sind nicht die gelegenheit haben
weiterhin so zu agieren eingegriffen
worden ist im öffentlichen dienst bei
den rentnerinnen und rentnern dass es
den so gut geht wie er mehrfach jetzt
ein weiteres mal rentenkürzung mitmachen
müssen was natürlich teilweise eine
katastrophe ist griechenland hat das
höchste niveau hat er immer noch nach
dem oecd statistiken hat immer noch
kritisiert die weltbank das höchste
rentenniveau relativ zum
bruttoinlandsprodukt
produkt pro kopf eingebrochen wieso die
anderen vereine und dann auf einmal die
renditen von fünf kleinen sohn den
deutschen lagen aber einsichtig man
dafür sorgt wenn man dafür sorgt dass
wirklich die industrie so einbricht und
das ist mit der politik passiert wie ist
denn das real doch diese hilfen haben
dazu geführt dass das inlandsprodukt
zusammengebrochen wer dachte der
leistung aber doch nicht die hilfen nein
jetzt verbringen die original ist das
produkt ist gesunken aber es ist nicht
auf die option eine hälfte nein aber es
ist gesunken können wir uns darauf
einigen und warum es ist gesund es ist
gesund die verteidigungs hochgegangen
und zwar vor dem ausbruch der krise vor
2008 dem lehman event da hat
griechenland sich dramatisch verschuldet
man muss bedenken bevor griechenland in
den euro kamen haben die zinsen von 25
prozent gezahlt das ist ja eine horrende
summe und dann haben sie in den euro ein
und mussten auf einmal nur noch die
deutschen zinsen zahlen die damals bei 5
prozent war dann haben sie sich
verschuldet das war so schön erstens hat
der staat auf die vorhandenen schulden
sehr viel geld gespart wir hätten die
steuern senken können und hätten immer
noch einfluss gehabt und zweitens war so
verlockend dieses geld zu nehmen man hat
sich verschuldet und hat den
staatssektor aufgebläht man hat sich
schnell in den schatten großer fehler
gewesen habe mich konservativen und
würde aber der weg daraus kann doch
nicht sein
eine andere länder noch mehr kaputt
gerne auf einem niveau das überhaupt der
wirtschaftsleistung des landes nicht
entspricht und ich werde nie mehr
wettbewerb
wo wir eigentlich über die vergangenheit
ich würde gerne über die zukunft reden
nämlich darüber welche reformen
notwendig sind wenn man sieht was die
schröders reformpolitik in deutschland
erreicht hat die agenda 20.10 müsste man
sich jetzt überlegen wenn man mal kosice
das ganz ähnliche vorschläge sind die
vorschläge gut und was können sie in
europa erreichen
ja also marco für meine begriffe zu
hause nicht viel machen
da hat er nicht gesagt er will an die 35
stunden woche nicht an er will das
renteneintrittsalter nicht ändern er
will also geld von anderen ländern
auf diese weise will seine wirtschaft
auf aufschwung bringen dann trage ich
noch umgekehrt wenn er solche
einschnitte wie wir ja in der agenda
20.10 hier in deutschland auch hatten
durch land oder in frankreich holen
würde das passieren
ja das wäre jedenfalls ein weg der
funktioniert man muss ja nun sagen die
agenda 2010 hat die deutsche
arbeitslosenquote jedenfalls nach der eu
messmethode von 12 prozent auf 4 prozent
reduziert
bedenken wir vor zwölf jahren als das
beschlossen wurde 13 jahren
da waren wir bei zwölf prozent
arbeitslosenquote das ist mehr als die
italiener und die franzosen heute haben
deutschland hatte jahrelang das
niedrigste wirtschaftswachstum gehabt
alle europäischen länder betrug also
jemand die rote laterne durch das
parlament um zu zeigen wir sind der
schlusslicht sie konnten die grenze am
ural ziehen es gab kein land das so
langsam wuchs wie deutschland und dann
kam die agenda die agenda hat uns einen
niedriglohnsektor geschaffen indem der
staat weniger geld für das wegbleiben
zahlte und mehr fürs mitmachen das ist
der kern der schröder schon reform also
konkret wurde die arbeitslosenhilfe für
millionen von leuten gestrichen und die
leute wurden heruntergestuft auf die
sozialhilfe
es war sehr hart für die betroffenen
keine frage gleichzeitig wurde einen
lohnzuschuss element eingeführt in form
des hartz 4 tarifes man kann ja heute
arbeiten und kriegt trotzdem noch hartz
iv dazu das war ja vorher nicht so
vorher gab es ein reines aufstockung
system einige die das nicht verstehen
denn das immer noch so heute aber das
ist heute total anders
sie kriegen einen echten lohnzuschuss
der sie in der summe aus dem
arbeitseinkommen und dem was über hartz
iv bekommen über den sockelbetrag von
hartz4 hinaus gibt und dadurch dass es
weniger geld für das wegbleiben vom
staat und mehr fürs mitmachen gab hat
sich der mindestlohn zu dem man bereit
war einen job anzunehmen gesenkt es war
kein gesetzlicher aber nehmt ihr zittern
mindestlohn und dadurch wurden
geschäftsmodelle plötzlich rentabel
die sonst nicht rentabel gewesen wären
es gab sehr viel mehr jobs keine tollen
wie gesagt aber jobs und in der summe
haben die leute mehr einkommen als wenn
man diese regelungen nicht betroffen
hätte zwar sind haben sich die löhne
ausgesprochen aber die lohnzuschüsse
treten ja hinzu und die netto
einkommensverteilung die die
fiskalischen effekte des staates mit
berücksichtigt hat sich laut schröder
nicht ins ungleiche bewegt sondern blieb
stabil und gleichzeitig diese jobs und
jobs sind eine integration der menschen
in die berufswelt sie sind nicht mehr
ausgegrenzt ihre kinder lernen auch dass
man da sind sie tätig sein kann
es ist eine auch in soziologischer
hinsicht und politischer hinsicht würde
ich mal sagen
der bessere weg eine inklusive
gesellschaft zu schaffen statt diese
ausgrenzung gesellschaft durch einen
sozialstaat der ghanaer fragen reformen
wirken die für europa für die einzelnen
länder in europa auch so greifen wie
hier
ich glaube herr sind hat ihn sehr
anschaulich das was real geschehens
geschildert das stimmt ich würde
folgende gegen thesen vertreten die
erste ist wird man kaum ähnliches tun
dann tritt das ein was sie vorhin gesagt
haben vorne pendelt bei der nächsten
präsidentschaftswahl gewinnen ich glaube
dass der fall schnell ganze weile hat ja
gerne rentenreform in frankreich ein
stückchen mehr kann sie machen aber das
wird dazu führen dass rechts ganz stark
wird deswegen ist ja meine hoffnung wir
haben ja noch parlamentswahlen in
frankreich das nicht das eintritt was
ich im moment was droht dass herr mag
die konservativen und die rechtsextreme
dort das parlament bestimmt
ich wünsche mir dort eine starke linke
mit der andere weg nicht er den herrn
sinn geschildert hat eintritt wenn alles
was sie sagen ist so korrekt sehr der
lohnbereich die löhne so nach unten
geöffnet worden
wir haben zwar immer noch fast drei
millionen arbeitslose männer aber es ist
deutlich weniger da haben sie völlig
recht aber gerne niedriglohnbereich das
führt dazu zu den problemen die wir im
lande auch haben wir haben heute
kinderarmut über zwei millionen sind
davon bedroht gerade heute früh zahlen
über 500.000 kinder leben seit mehr als
vier jahren im hartz-iv-bereich ein
skandal in dem reichen land vier jahre
hat die große koalition regiert hat dort
nichts getan
diese öffnung nach unten ist ein großes
problem und hat in der hamburger
schlüssel bekommen nein kinderarmut wäre
ein skandal aber übrigen handelsbereich
als definition der skandal zu nehmen ist
doch absurd
das system der sozialen stadt erhalten
während sie arbeiten und gibt ihnen noch
was dazu ist da sie nicht von ihrer
hände arbeit alleine leben und gehören
zwei einkommen haben wir der skandal der
skandale liga etwas was eigentlich das
im zentrum der arge poing liegt und
wirkung bedrohung richtig sie haben
völlig recht im zentrum der schröder
superform dass im ergebnis ist heute so
ist das deutschland 120 milliarde hat 1
2 millionen millionäre und hat kinder in
armut und 500.000 kinder im hartz iv
bereich seit vier jahren arbeiten wir
haben 30.000 wo obdachlose kinder
das ist alles im reichen deutschland da
ist etwas schwer ich finde das nicht
akzeptabel wenn leute milliardäre
leistungslosen sich verärgert und auf
der anderen seite müssen kinder auf der
straße leben das verträgen land das kann
man noch mal als ich glaube noch mal
dass ein solcher weg dazu führen würde
dass die rechts vorne pen gestärkt wird
deswegen ist es der falsche weg er würde
ja genau dasselbe machen
er würde den versuch machen
niedriglohnbereich etwas zu öffnen
das würde die konkurrenz lage für
deutschland fällt zwar schwer aber ich
glaube genau das gegenteil ist der fall
wir müssen in deutschland dafür sorgt
dass löhne steigen dass der
niedriglohnsektor ernsthaft bekämpfen
das ist der punkt damit tun wir mehr für
frankreich und auch für griechenland
wenn bei uns das lohnniveau steigt wenn
die exportindustrie ist nicht mehr das
deutschland zum beispiel im bereich von
nahrungsmitteln jetzt ein großer
exporteur ist sie haben es ja für
holländische tomaten geschildert es gibt
es wie bei anderen dingen auch dass
deutschland milch exportiert das wir
hähnchenschenkel exportieren nicht nach
europa sondern auch nach afrika
das sind problem und das hat mit dem
möglichen niedriglohnsektor zu tun
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass wird
es nicht sein nicht nach unten öffnung
sondern wir müssen für ausgleich für bei
langsam in europa in den einzelnen
ländern
und da muss man an die obszönen
reichtümer an und man muss einen
ausgleich zwischen den ländern schaffen
alles andere ist eine illusion weil es
ansonsten letztlich zu einem zum
wettbewerb und zur konkurrenz zwischen
ländern und regionen führt wo immer
verlierer dabei sind ist das möglich
diesen ausgleich in europa herzustellen
glauben wir dass das funktionieren kann
also ich glaube wir sollten wenn wir
europäische integration vorantreiben
wollen was wir sollten bin ein
überzeugter europäer schauen in andere
länder und kopieren was funktioniert hat
er habe ich zwei beispiele vor augen
das eine ist die schweiz und das andere
ist die vereinigten staaten von amerika
beides sind föderale system mit sehr
viel autonomie für die anderen
gebietskörperschaften die kantone oder
die staaten gleichzeitig haben sie einen
zentralstaat wenn wir mal historisch
schauen wie diese staatengebilde
entstanden sind so sind sie zunächst als
militärische sicherheitsbündnis
entstanden
das hat die staatlichkeit begründet und
dann allmählich im laufe der
jahrhunderte kann man schon fast an oder
der vielen jahrzehnte jedenfalls
kam das fiskalische hinterher mit
gemeinsamen aufgaben aber es gibt in
beiden ländern nicht viel umverteilung
zwischen den regionen es ist sogar so
wenn wir auf das thema euro bonds
zurückkehren die amerikaner haben ja in
ihrer anfangsphase das mal probiert mit
amerika bonns wenn sie so wollen ja also
alexander hamilton der erste
finanzminister hat 1791 die schulden der
einzelstaaten vergemeinschaftet und zu
bundesschulden gemacht oder gesagt hat
das ist jetzt zement für den neuen
amerikanischen staat und dann wurde 1813
zweiten krieg gegen die briten noch mal
sozialisiert die folge war dass die
staaten das passt prima verschulden kann
man sich und die schuldenlast liegt beim
zentralstaat dann haben sie geld
aufgenommen um straßenbrücke brücken
kanäle zu bauen es gab einen riesigen
wirtschaftsaufschwung in dem land denn
der wurde aber zu einer blase und die
blase platzte von 1837 bis 42 sind neun
von 29 amerikanischen staaten in konkurs
gegangen formal und die anderen konnten
gar nicht helfen weil sie auch belastet
waren und der britische historiker
britisch amerikanische historiker er
harry james aus princeton zieht eine
linie von 1842 auf 1861 als der
sezessionskrieg bekannte nicht als
streit und haas war entstanden durch die
fehlgeschlagene schulden union
natürlich waren es in erster linie die
sklaven probleme aber er sagt diese
ungelöste schuldenfrage trug bei zu den
spannungen die sich ein boden im
bürgerkrieg und erst nach dem
bürgerkrieg haben die amerikaner ihr
system trägt wie heute das heißt ein no
bail out system was wir ja auch dann in
den maastrichter vertrag eingeschrieben
haben das heißt wenn ein staat pleite es
ist pleite und es hilft ihm nicht der
steuerzahler eines anderen staates
er muss selber mit den gläubigern zu
recht kommen und die gläubiger die ihm
das geld leihen
sie müssen wissen was sie tun sie müssen
wissen dass sie vielleicht nicht wieder
kriegen und wenn sie das wissen gehen
sie von vornherein nicht zu viel und es
kann keine blase entstehen das ist das
konstruktionsprinzip das ist in der
schweiz genau dasselbe
wenn ein kanton pleite geht hilft kein
anderer kanton und deswegen sind die
geldgeber des kantons sehr vorsichtig
bei der kreditvergabe und verlangen auch
wenn er sich überschuldet hören sind
dieses würde man alles aufgeben wenn wir
jetzt in euro-bonds gehen das führt dazu
dass die zinsaufschläge nicht mehr da
sind die gläubiger sind bereit den
windigsten staat zu finanzieren der
verschuldet sich angesichts der
niedrigen zinsen und das macht jeder so
wir gehen in eine schuldenunion und zum
schluss endet das ganze in einem riesen
kladderadatsch das ist im moment eine
gewisse erleichterung weil die
finanzmärkte happy sind dass sie ihr
geld wieder kriegen ja komischerweise
haben wir ja hier eine allianz zwischen
der wall street und unter city auf
landen auf der einen seite und so
manchen sozialdemokratischen
vorstellungen an der stelle was mich
immer wundert franken ja ein 1 1
haftungs system haben was ökonomischen
grundprinzipien genügt und dann kann man
auch eine solide föderation
ich würde gerne einen punkt mehr würde
gerne einen punkt aufgreifen denn berlin
hat gesagt dass man die europäische
union einigen könnte zum beispiel eine
gemeinsame verteidigungspolitik weil das
sozusagen eine ein eigenes element ihrer
würden sie dem zustimmen
wissen sie ich bin ja ein gegner von
überhaupt von militärbündnis und den
ganzen militärischen engagement weil ich
schon glaube dass das was auch von
europa dort gemacht worden ist zudem
krisen die wir haben mit beigetragen hat
denn es ist so wer weiterhin und das
macht die europäische union deutschland
auch waffen in alle welt exportiert ist
ja auch ein teil eines militärbündnisses
der organisiert auch dass menschen
kommen und das ist derzeit die situation
dass den 13 mandaten im ausland in
deutschland das wir drittgrößter
waffenexporteur sind und dass wir da
eine zentrale rolle einnimmt dass europa
leider in dezentralen krisenregionen
keine rolle spielt das ein problem also
muss ich ja nur syrien angucken da am
letztlich die vereinigten staaten und
russland miteinander geredet und gesagt
jetzt hören wir auch dort an der stelle
dann hat er trump in abstimmung mit
mit moskau dort einfach mal ohne
irgendein mandat bombardiert europa
schaut dort nur zu
ich würde mir wünschen dass wir
außenpolitisch deutlich stärker sind
dass wir mehr tun um die krisen der welt
zu bewältigen
aber ohne eine gemeinsame
verteidigungspolitik ohne eine
gemeinsame verteidigungspolitik solches
real auch schon es gibt extreme
austauschen und ähnlich ist aber das
muss man nicht primär nehme ich glaube
dass auch wieder so eine klassische
deutsche diskussion über das 2 prozent
hier wird so engagiert diskutiert und
ich sage es einer der größten fehler
seit jahrzehnten gibt es das 0 7 prozent
fiel bei der entwicklungspolitik und wir
sind mit 1044 weit davon weg da frage
ich mich wieso ist dort nicht mehr
engagement da muss ich ja sogar herrn
müller csu loben der entwicklungspolitik
sich immer engagiert und sagt ich muss
mehr passieren damit wir vor ort
probleme lösen das wäre völlig richtig
aber da es außer worten auch nicht viel
also ich glaube dass der weg über
gemeinsame verteidigung strukturen der
bedroht eigentlich europa wo sind
eigentlich die länder die uns so heftig
angreifen würde irgendwas von putin
erzählt ich glaube das ist absurd ist
ein russe will kriegt diese diskussion
sollten wir mal dahin führen dass man
gemeinsam man gemeinsam daran baut was
mein ziel war ein europäisches haus
militär ist da nicht dass ich das gerne
hier sind es klappen quadratmeter sein
und ich werde jetzt noch eine ganz kurze
schlussstände der bitte um eine kurze
antwort sondern sagen europa steht im
moment wirklich am scheideweg
ja es geht
wieder mal am scheideweg aber es gibt
nicht nur zwei wege
es gibt nicht nur den weg von marco und
das verderben es gibt auch noch einen
rationalen zwischen weg es gibt noch
einen rationalen weg und das ist der
linke weg europa ist in der größten
krise die es je gegeben hat
exit rechtsextremismus
jugendarbeitslosigkeit sind symptome und
wenn wir so weitermachen noch vier jahre
mit dem diktat von merkel und schäuble
wird europa scheitern
das muss jetzt vor schluss auch noch das
haben sie sehr geschickt gemacht für
diese diskutiert und bedanke mich fertig
[Musik]